[Music]
So, welcome back. We're here some
interesting things I've learned and
we've talked about in our last
broadcast. I pray that you were here and
you heard all of these things. Uh, this
is not a stranger to the body of Christ
nor on this topic. And, uh, Dr. Wallak
is here with us again and I'm happy to
welcome him to Living by Faith
broadcast. Doc, thank you for being with
me again.
Pastor Mike, I feel like family. I
really appreciate your hospitality.
Oh, I appreciate you so much. Now, now
just talk. Yesterday, we talked about
eating eggs. I've been removing the yolk
from my eggs because they they
Well, you were given this information.
Okay. Uh this all started out in 1901
uh when the German Navy went to a um
German chemist by the name of Wilhelm
Norman in Berlin University said look we
need a synthetic smokeless diesel
lubricant for German submarines by 1904
he'd done it at the end of the first
world war they didn't need it anymore so
he was allowed to sell it to a British
soap manufacturing company they couldn't
sell the soap because everybody buys
making their own soap so they sold it to
Proctor and Gamble here in the states
come on
and they couldn't sell it remember this
is a diesel lubricant for German
submarines. Yes, sir.
They couldn't sell it as soap because in
the 20s, 30s, 40s, everybody's making
their own soap.
And so, they decided to turn it into a
cooking shortening called Krisco.
Remember, this is a synthetic diesel
engine lubricant for German submarines.
Now, it's going to be a cooking
sharpening. And grandma didn't want to
use it because she's using lard,
buttercream, and egg. Absolutely. Like
her 40 generations of grandmas before
her. Well, so this guy by the name of
Anel Keys, who's the head of department
of medicine at the University of
Minnesota, was on the board of directors
of Proctor and Gamble, is also on the
board of directors of the American Heart
Association, and he brokers a deal by
which Proctor and Gamble gives the
American Heart Association $1.7 million,
which is a kind of chump change today
for big institutions. Back then, it was
a lot of money.
Yes, sir.
So, they took it in exchange for
endorsing Crisco as a healthier way to
eat than buttercream, lard, and eggs.
They couldn't sell it. So Anel Keys goes
to an advertising firm said, "How do we
sell this?" Well, he said, 'You have to
demonize what grandma's doing.
Ah,
so then she'll go to the heaven piece
with church music and butterflies
is going to be the
Crisco.
Well, they did an analysis of lard
buttercream and eggs. They got two
common threads, cholesterol and
saturated fat. So they started
demonizing that just so they could sell
the Crisco.
Okay. And then they threw in the
Mediterranean diet, which there was no
research on, nothing. They just made it
up out of their head. And that began to
sell. It was romantic. So they began to
sell the Crisco.
Well, since then, we've gotten about 14
diseases
that going to Crisco instead of lard
buttercream and eggs. Okay. We switched
and the switch we wound up with low tea,
low testosterone, ED, erectile
dysfunction, menopause at age 30.
Oh wow. adrenal exhaustion and
Alzheimer's disease.
All those are caused by a cholesterol
deficiency.
It turns out the cholesterol is an
essential nutrient and it has nothing to
do with the cause of plugged arteries
and plaque in your arteries. It's all it
was all a fraud to sell Krisco
and and and so by people have to be
sitting here just like I when I first
heard you some years ago
by what authority do you speak? Who is
this guy? And and you're brilliant. All
of the information you have concerning
all of these deficiencies.
Well, well, Pastor Mike,
um, this thing, this story about the
Crisco and and Yes, sir. and, um,
getting rid of cholesterol, winding up
with all these cholesterol defic
diseases was a two full page story in
the Wall Street Journal three years ago.
Now, you realize the Wall Street Journal
is a financial newspaper. Yes, sir.
So, when they talk about health or
anything like that, it's always one
column wide, two paragraphs long. Very,
we're talking
We're talking two full pages to tell
this story.
Then a couple years later, five full
pages in Time magazine, same story.
Come on.
And nobody paid attention to it. Even
though on the cover of these things,
they're telling you about don't listen
to this thing about don't eat the eggs,
eat butter, don't use margarine, eat
butter. All the opposite of what the
doctors have been telling us. That was
all to sell Krisco.
Absolutely.
And so we wound up with all these
diseases. They're happy because they
make billions of dollars each year for
the sale of seais and Viagra and and
Premrin which is made out of horses
urine for women to get artificial
estrogen for for um menopause at age 30.
Yes, sir. Yes, sir.
And then they make billions. No, they
make trillions of dollars on statin
drugs to lower your blood cholesterol.
That's what makes the doctors and the
pharmaceutical companies really happy
because now they get to treat Alzheimer
disease which is caused by a deficiency
of cholesterol. and your mind is just
clicking away like
Well, that's because I've done 8,000
human autopsies. I've done 40,000 animal
autopsies.
You've done 8,000 human autopsies.
Yes, sir. And and 40,000 animal
autopsies from 454 species of animals.
Nobody else has ever done that before.
I'm not smarter than anybody else. But
God has put me in a position
absolutely
to to be confronted with all this
information. And as a result, I know
things that nobody else knows. They've
seen it with their eyes, but they didn't
couldn't understand it. They couldn't
interpret it because they didn't have
the information.
Mhm.
And so that's
and most of these autopsies that you
have
they're published.
Okay. And and you have also witnessed
the deficiencies.
Yes sir. Well, this is all done by
biochemistry. Yes, sir.
We spent millions of dollars doing the
biochemistries, all the tests. And
again, this is why my 1200page book.
That's my essentially my PhD thesis.
1200 page book that came out of this uh
study is in the Smithsonian Institute is
a national treasure because you cannot
find this information anywhere else.
Come on. So, so these black
uh genetic lies,
talk about that.
Okay. Well, this all started um when I
actually rebuilt Andy Young's knees. he
was going to get a double knee
replacement, rebuilt his knee so he
didn't need the surgery. He was
introducing me. He was so excited about
it. We were talking about cickle cell
anemia and hummingbirds and deer and why
he could get a quote genetic disease
unquote from the black community into
deer and hummingbirds, which is really
just nutritional deficiency, not not
genetic as doctors would say.
And um so I was able to rebuild Andy
Young's knees with our nutritional
program. So he didn't need surgery. And
um
I believe that's what
kind of contributed to my mom passing
away. Uh she needed knee replacement at
80 something years.
Well, you should never have done surgery
on her 80 something.
Right. Absolutely.
I could have rebuilt her in say 90 days
and she'd still be alive today
using God's principles.
Now, so Crelo Dollar and Andy Young
called me in 1991. They said, 'L um
Emery University has told us that Pastor
Dollar's daughter is not going to make
it. She's 11 and a half years old. She's
got a genetic form of asthma found in
black kids, and she's not responding to
maintenance medication nor to emergency
medication. And she's not going to live
to V12. She's having so many crises now
with her asthma.
Emory University says she's not going to
live to be age 12. Get ready for her
loss because tomorrow you could wake up,
she'll be dead.
It's going to happen quick.
So they call, "Can you do anything?" I
said, "Yes, I I know what's happening
here. I can help you. I can get rid of
that." They were putting their hand over
the phone. I could hear him whispering.
She said, "I'm sure pastor daughter
said, "Well, Emry University said
genetic. There's nothing we can do.
She's going to die." Yeah.
And here's this guy. I don't even know
who he is, and he's saying he can help
her. Said, "Get back on."
And so, I said, "Yes." I said, "The
reason why she's not responding to the
maintenance medication and the emergency
medication is she's not absorbing it.
She has something called gluten
intolerance. She's her intestines are
damaged. She cannot absorb the
medication.
That's the problem. So, we need to get
her and your whole family, everybody in
the family, grandma and pastor Taffy and
everybody in the household and the cook
and needs to be on um a gluten-free
diet. No fried foods, no processed
meats, no oils, no glutens, no wheat,
broats. And then here's the program for
her to rebuild her lungs and get rid of
her asthma. And praise God. Praise God,
pastor. In two weeks she was cured
after 11 and a half years going
downhill.
In two weeks she was cured using God's
stuff.
Wow.
And so un unsolicited a month later I
get this very large check. Lots of zeros
on it. Come on.
From Pastor Dollar.
Come on.
And I don't take any money for telephone
consultations, giving lectures. I don't
take the money for the sale of the
product. I don't make anything from the
sale of the product because I don't want
people to think I'm doing this
I love it. I love it. Yes, sir.
I don't want people to think I'm doing
this for the money.
Yes, sir. I don't make any money for the
sale of products. Yeah.
And so I said, I have to give you this
check back and I I'm calling you to tell
you this personally because I didn't
want you to think I was rude and
rejecting your check and I just want to
thank you for your kind thoughts. He
said, "Well, can you do research?" I
said, "Yes, sir. What kind of research
you want?" He said, "Well, after what
you did for my daughter, I want you to
find out all the diseases that are said
to be genetic in the black community
that are not. I want to know how to
prevent them and cure them."
Oh, you got to stop right there. You got
to stop right there cuz once we return,
we want to talk about this information
that uh Doc put together and it's going
to bless your life. Stay tuned. Don't go
anywhere.
Hi, I'm Dr. Joel Wallik and I'm going to
give you the truth about nutrition. What
I would like you to do is give me 90
days to show what the 90s essential
nutrients can do for your health. For
more information on this topic and more,
go to truthaboutnutrition.com.
We're We're back and I want to get right
back into
Black Jeans Lies.
That's right.
Yeah.
And we do have a book and we have two
CDs that go along with it.
And the research was paid for by Pastor
Creo Dollar.
Okay.
Okay. And he wanted
I love Doc. That's my main man. I I
thank God for him. Yeah. Oh, yeah. He's
been such a wonder um introducing me
more and more great things that God
does. Absolutely. Appreciate him.
And um so any rate, he he sends me this
money, which I can't take. So wanted to
send it back to me. He says, "Well, do
the research with it." And and what did
he want research?
You can't take it because you're not in
it for
for the money.
For the money. You You sincerely want us
to know the body of Christ, God's
message.
That's correct.
I love it. And so
all over the world.
Yes, sir.
55 countries have done the sin. 55
countries
and the United Nations.
You could be a very very wealthy
beyond
well I'm I'm wealthy in God's spirit but
I could have lots of money but I don't
take it.
And so Pastor Dollar um he sends us
money and I say I can't take the money.
He says well can you do research?
And I said well what kind of research
you want? He says I want you to find all
the diseases that are said to be genetic
in the black community that are not. How
to prevent them? How to cure them? So I
hired a bunch of graduate students with
the money and in six months time I had
all the research I needed. I sent him
the manuscript to the book before I
published it. I wanted his input this is
where where we're going with this. This
is what we found.
And he was just shocked because all the
diseases said to be genetic in the black
community, high pressure, diabetes,
obesity, heart disease, cancer,
celmia are not
are not.
No, they're not. They're just all simple
nutritional deficiency diseases. Cickle
cell anemia is a nutritional deficiency
in the mother when the bone marrow cells
are forming in early pregnancy embryo
and so this sort of like cerebral paly
and heart defects and cleft pallet and
down syndrome. This is a birth defect of
the bone marrow and so it only makes
dysfunctional hemoglobin called cickle
cell anemia.
Now it also occurs in animals because
they can get the same birth effect.
That's why my books in the Smithsonian
Institute right all vertebrates same
deficiency get the same disease. White
people also get cickle cell anemia.
Now it's supposed to be a genetic
disease in black folks
certainly.
And so they had to change the name in
white guys. Same disease but they call
itthalismia in white guys.
How about that?
Otherwise it would confuse the public.
Of course. Yeah. Right.
And so um what I had to learn to do was
come up with programs to eliminate um
cickle cell anemia, high blood pressure,
diabetes, obesity, heart disease. For
instance, congestive heart failure. As a
pastor, you see lots of people with
congestive heart.
Absolutely. Yes, sir.
Sir, we've known for 300 years that say
deficiency of a single vitamin.
A single vitamin.
Yes, sir. The quickest ones I've gotten
rid of of congestive heart failure is a
week. Normally, it took me two months or
less. Get them off all their medication.
are free of of congestive heart failure
because it's a you know for instance um
when you have iron deficiency anemia you
and I would want to go to the drugstore
and get some iron
but the doctor wants to do a bone marrow
transplant
well that's why all the insurance
companies are going broke because
they're
going with all these expensive
treatments that just treat the symptoms
right
don't fix the disease whereas the
nutritional supplementation
cures the disease
and some of them people know you can
cure scurvy with vitamin C you can cure
berry berry vitamin B1, plaggra with
vitamin B3, rico vitamin D. You can cure
um let's see here uh you can cure um
there's a type of anemia you get with
vitamin B12 deficiency obviously iron
deficienc
you can't see colors at night.
Yes sir.
It's a simple vitamin A deficiency.
What about the congested heart failure?
Well, I don't tell people what that is
because I don't want them to go drop off
their medication and get that vitamin
because they might have a problem.
What we have is what we call the healthy
brain and heart pack,
okay?
Which is a more complete thing because
when you have congestive heart failure,
you got lung problems, you got kidney,
and so we have to deal with all of that
and then we give them what we call the
secret sauce, which is that vitamin.
Okay.
We add that secret sauce to
the secret sauce. Now, how can they find
out if we're here?
Well, the number you're giving them.
Yes, sir. uh that number, the email
address, the website, the telephone
number, Miss Linda, our angel, will be
their coach.
Absolutely. Absolutely. And walk them
through that step by step
and they won't have to be concerned
about there being any imbalances with
correct what they're getting from their
doctor and
no, they can stay on their medication,
right? And when they go to their doctor
for their usual, in fact, if they're
feeling really, really good, I say go
make an extra, you know, don't wait
until you're supposed to go there three
months from now. Just get an
appointment. Go ahead. See what he says
now. He said, "I don't know why, but you
don't have congestive heart failure
anymore." I get this all the time with
diabetes. People with diabetes for 30
years, pastor, they call me my doctor
says I don't have diabetes anymore. Not
to take any more medication
in 30 days.
After 30 years,
this is God's word.
It never fails.
I know when I got out of that hospital
after almost
checking out. I mean, the doctors were
This is very, very, very scary. It is a
challenging time for us all,
but I got to work on taking all of those
things that you were telling me about.
And uh people are telling me that I look
Now, I I don't want to be boasting about
how I look, but
Well, you look like a young man. Your
skin looks beautiful.
Yeah. Yeah. And And that's what I've
been hearing. I mean my strength I'm
regaining
it's almost daily uh
and and I just feel a lot better. The
the pressure that I would have uh
challenges with was nor is normalized
and I just thought it was my exercise
a combination of that but this
deficiency that I obviously had. Now,
you had lung problems, didn't you?
Yes, sir. Lung problem, as
I remember. Mhm.
And of course, the lungs make a hormone
to keep the bronchi open.
Okay.
Keep your airways open.
If you're not making that hormone, those
airways, the muscles just close it down.
So, instead of being as big around as a
quarter,
okay,
your bronchi to your lungs from your
trachea.
Yeah.
Okay. Instead of being a diameter of a
quarter, they're the size of a dime of a
pencil.
Oh, you know, maybe maybe an eighth of
an inch.
Yeah.
So, you can't hardly breathe.
Yes, sir. and D, oh, you got a
life-threatening situation here. What
should you do?
Yeah.
Well, I've had people who were told they
only have weeks to live. They call me up
in the middle of the night. We put them
on, say, 18 of these nutrients and by
the morning time their bronai are back
open to the size of a quarter. They're
perfectly normal.
You just have to give them the right
secret sauce.
And this is what's on the CD. The right
secret sauce, the correct secret sauce.
And all of them are gods. These are
man's creation. Every one of these is a
natural substance made by
So did you go back like to Genesis, if
you will, plant-based, and you've
researched all the information that
matches certain different dispositions
of the body and have connected that
particular
vitamin with like the lungs and what you
just mentioned, the heart and
and doc doctors don't pay attention to
this because they're looking for the
drug that's going to open up your
bronchi. Doesn't solve the nutritional
deficiency problem,
right?
But the drug will relieve the symptoms,
but the disease, what's going to happen
is when you're deficient in that same
nutrient,
you're going to get a blood clot in your
lung. You're going to get a a thrombotic
stroke or you get a blood clot in the
brain or you get a coronary thrombosis,
you get a blood clot in a coronary
artery and die
because the same deficiency causes all
those different diseases. Mhm.
Well, why aren't doctors
talk about that a bit?
Well, um let's look for two minutes on
some statistics.
Okay.
Um John's Hopkins, very famous medical
school from Baltimore, Maryland.
Okay.
They came out three months ago and said
the number three cause of death in human
beings in America is simple mistakes in
the workplace of a doctor.
Third leading cause of death in America
is simple mistakes in doctor's workplace
to hospital.
Each year, now this is John's Hopkins
came up with this just a couple of
months ago,
published in medical journals. Every
newspaper in the land had it was on
every TV station.
They said each year medical doctors kill
and they use a kill word. Each year
medical doctors kill 251,000 Americans
from simple mistakes. What would happen
if a fast food place were to kill
251,000?
How about that? Yes. Yes, sir. What
would happen if Iran or North Korea were
to send over intercontinental ballistic
missile with a bad weapon and kill
251,000 Americans being war?
Absolutely obvious.
Well, here's one trade that does it
every year in the workplace and nothing
happens.
Also, we've learned that because of
these things, our children will be the
first generation of Americans that do
not live as long as their parents. You
may have heard that, too.
Absolutely.
Well, that is a catastrophic prediction
of biblical proportions. That's the same
as telling the Pharaoh, the firstborn in
Egypt are gonna die if you don't let the
Hebrew slaves go.
Okay. And this what's going to happen if
we don't supplement these kids properly.
They will all die before we do.
Get this message out more and more of
them.
Well, you're doing it.
Yes, sir.
And again, it's all in the CDs and the
DVDs and the books. And um we're working
hard and I can't thank you enough for
sharing this with your church family.
Absolutely.
And uh some of them will take it on like
apostles and uh and sometimes you feel
the frustration. I I felt the
frustration and then I thought of Noah
and Jesus himself.
Come on.
They couldn't get everybody to do
everything.
Come on. Come on. Come on. We got to
stop right there, D. We're coming right
back to share with you just some tips
and things that you should know now.
Stay tuned.
Hi, I'm Dr. Joel Wallik and I'm going to
give you the truth about nutrition. What
I would like you to do is give me 90
days to show what the 90s essential
nutrients can do for your health. For
more information on this topic and more,
go to truthaboutnutrition.com.
It's been an awesome broadcast. I want
Dr. Wallik to just give us some tips.
But I also want you to get in contact
with them. You've heard some things
that's going to literally revolutionize
your life. It's it's going to change
your life. It's changed my life. My
health is a lot better. I'm telling you,
I'm doing everything this man has given
me to do. You can contact him now. Uh
his precious angel, he calls her, Linda.
She'll be on standby. Just contact her
at this number that's on your screen and
he and you'll have all the information
you'll need from that call. I promise
you. Doc, give us few tips on what we
can start doing. Now, if I got high
blood pressure, what what what do I do?
If if I have diabetes, I call how do I
get started? Give me some tips.
Okay. Well, first of all, all
vertebrates, again, humans, turtles,
fish, flamingos, and elephants and
giraffe, and rats, and dogs and pigs, we
require 90 essential nutrients, 60
minerals, 16 vitamins, 12 amassids,
three fatty acids. Most multiples on the
market have 24, 26, 28, but not even a
third.
We require 90.
We require 90. Of those 90, 60 are
minerals.
Now, plants only require three minerals
to look good and produce tomatoes and
carrots and seeds for the next
generation.
We need 60.
Okay? Okay.
So, you're eating a pretty good looking
tomato. Tastes good, firm, perfect
tomato.
You're only getting three
elements from the soil. You're short 57.
Yes, sir. Yes, sir.
Okay. And so, we have to consciously
supplement with these things because
these nutrients are no longer found in
the food. There's some places in the
United States 50, 100, 200 years ago,
those all 60 minerals were in the
tomatoes.
How about that?
Now, there's only three because our soil
is deficient.
Yes, sir. Well, they're deficient
because we went from wood as the
universal fuel to electricity.
You're probably old enough to remember
when we put wood ashes in the garden.
Absolutely.
Wood ashes are not ashes. Wood ashes are
the minerals that the trees sucked up
out of the ground.
We threw the minerals into the garden.
We ate the tomatoes with the carrots and
the beets and the cabbage.
They had sucked up all those minerals
up. They didn't need them,
but they sucked them up. We ate that
food and we got the minerals that way.
How about that?
We switched to electricity. No more wood
ashes in the house anymore. No more wood
ashes in the garden. No more minerals.
The commercial fertilizers only have the
three that plants need.
Come on.
So, we went from
40 50 60 Yeah. to three.
Three, right?
And nobody knew to make up the
difference by supplementing because
nobody knew they were getting their
minerals from the food.
Okay.
So, now we know this.
And so, we have to consciously
supplement. And I like people to get
every day. Every day, right?
A stick of butter a day.
Okay.
You need to eat a stick of butter a day.
It's not an apple a day keeps the doctor
away. says stick a butter a day keeps
the doctor away. Okay. It helps you get
rid of and reverses Alzheimer's disease,
Parkinson disease, MS, liaric disease,
hunting disease. All those diseases of
the brain are really the same disease.
Just different parts of the brain are
more severely affected. So you get
slightly different symptoms.
And we were told that a stick of butter
a day will kill us.
Well, cause plaque in your arteries and
cause Yeah. All kinds of arterial
disease. No, sir. The margarine is the
one that actually does it. Okay. And
then of course again I like people to
per 100 pounds of body weight to eat six
to eight eggs a day.
That's so you can make hormones. Okay
testosterone, estrogen, progesterone,
adrenal hormones belong to a class of
nutrients called steroid hormones.
They're 95% by weight cholesterol.
And if you get if you're eating margin
instead of butter and you're eating egg
beaters instead of eggs or egg white
omelets instead of whole egg omelettes,
you think you're doing good because the
doctor told you so.
That's exactly what
you're deficient all those hormones.
you're going to be needing Seialis and
Viagra and Bremeran and
oh Lord oh Lord Lord okay I'm going to
eat some eggs today
the the the kicker was in in 1991 there
was an article published in the New
England Journal of Medicine by Harvard
Medical School
okay
and there was this old guy he's 88 years
old and he looked like he was 50 and his
blood work showed he was a healthy 50-y
old guy although he was 88 years old and
so this professor who was trying to
teach newly graduated doctors about
seniors he says let's look at this guy
and he said well why sir do you eat or
what do you attribute your youthful
looks to and your youthful uh blood
work? He says, "Well, I eat 25 eggs a
day." What? Yeah, I've been doing it for
17 years. I'm going to do it for the
next 100 years. He said, "Why do you eat
25 eggs a day?" He said, "Because it
gives me the sex life of an
18-year-old."
Come on.
And so, this was published. This is one
of the biggest articles ever written in
the New England Journal of Medicine. Eat
25 eggs a day.
I'm going to get some eggs as soon as we
end this broadcast.
And I'm not here to make light of any of
all of this information. This
information at all. This information has
really been
They can look it up. March 1991, New
England Journal of Medicine.
You look it up yourself. You heard it
here. Look it up. Look it up. And uh and
then please contact his office. That
information is on the screen. um his
darling angel Linda will be there to
take your calls and uh it it's going to
change your life. I'm glad you tuned in.
This has been Living by Faith. Remember,
life is better when you're living by
faith. We'll see you soon.
Thank you for viewing Living by Faith.
If you would like to obtain a copy of
today's lesson or any other featured
item, please give us a call at
1888-630-4540.
Dead doctors don't lie. With more than
200 million copies in circulation,
recorded during Dr. Wallik's lectures,
this CD touches on a wide range of
subjects including aging, heart disease,
cholesterol, arthritis, cancer,
diabetes, Alzheimer's, and pregnancy. In
all, Dr. Wallik addresses 25 topics and
engages in question and answer sessions
with the audience. And his book is a
comprehensive expansion of the material
on the CD with over 400 pages of
information which can significantly
impact your quality and length of life.
You'll learn how to identify 90
essential nutrients, many of which are
not available in food. Prevent and
reverse 412 diseases with vitamins,
minerals, and herbs. Reach your genetic
potential for a long and happy life.
Eliminate a major portion of costly
medical expenses. Take responsibility
for your health and much, much more. Dr.
Wallock's Dead Doctors Don't Lie 400page
book and multi-millionelling CD can both
be yours today for a gift of $40. It's
not too early or too late to gain the
knowledge and tools you must have to
rescue and revolutionize your health and
that of your family and loved ones. Call
or order online today.
If you're ever in the Washington or
Baltimore metropolitan areas, we invite
you to worship with us at one of our
Saturday evening or Sunday morning
services. Please give us a call at
1888-630-454.